we're joined now by dr ashish jaw he's
dean of brown university school of
public health
dr zhao always good to see you lucky us
you're here on a day we really need
stuff to sort out nobody better than you
at this
so let's get started we just heard dr
burke say
uh that it's up to the future looks
devastating right now
and i guess the question is i've heard
described as a dangerous tipping point
i guess my question to you right away is
why is this happening and why is it
happening now
yeah good morning gail and thank you for
having me on um it's happening i think
because people are getting tired of all
the restrictions
and i think uh we're heading into colder
weather where people are spending more
time indoors
and people are letting their guard down
and again the things that we've talked
about in the past like mask wearing is
very uneven
and put all of that together and we are
seeing i think a
dangerous acceleration of cases
hospitalizations and deaths yeah you
heard the president say last night on 60
minutes that the reason why the number's
so high
is because we keep testing so much does
he have a point
you know unfortunately i wish he was
right but he doesn't because
while we are testing more than we were
testing back in april or may
our testing has been reasonably flat
over the last month six weeks up a
little bit
but what is really going on is a lot
more infections and we can see that in
the fact that hospitalizations and
deaths are also climbing
more testing wouldn't explain that you
know the other thing we look at cases
like little maggie that just because you
get the
get coveted doesn't mean it's going to
be a a
fatal a fatal infection for you the
thing is you don't know
you don't know if you're going to be one
of the lucky ones who gets it and then
doesn't have very severe symptoms
and doesn't require hospitalization then
you have maggie who's young
who gets it and then still has lingering
lingering effects
yeah you know this is a very unusual
virus in that
large chunk of people end up having very
mild symptoms
obviously a small proportion of people
end up dying but there's another
probably 10 or 20 percent
of all people who get infected who end
up getting pretty sick
and sometimes recover and sometimes just
end up having long-term symptoms
it's really much much better to avoid
this virus than to sort of
you know uh roll the dice and hope that
you're one of the lucky ones
i totally agree we just heard chief of
staff mark meadows say listen we cannot
control this pandemic
and then when he when he when he was
asked why not he said because it's a
contagious virus
is that the way to look at it we can't
control it
no i mean i don't know where to begin on
that gail
uh there are lots of contagious viruses
uh we control
many of them most of them lots of
countries have controlled this virus
the idea that america is somehow
uniquely incapable of managing to
control an infectious disease
strikes me as odd we certainly can't
control it and we should
now vice president mike pence as you
heard is on the campaign trail he's
considered an essential
personnel but people close to him as
chief of staff his body man three other
aides have tested positive
he's head of the coronavirus task force
dr zhang should he be out
campaigning during this time
you know gail this is not a close call
he should absolutely not
be out of quarantine the cdc makes
special dispensation
for people whose work involves critical
infrastructure
so it's not about essential personnel
obviously he's vice president that's
important
it's about are you doing things that are
critically important for the health and
well-being of the country
i don't think any of us think
campaigning as important as it is
is critical infrastructure for our
country he should really be in
quarantine
all right dr xia i'm going to send him
your number he needs to have a
conversation with you
thank you so much for joining us this
morning we really appreciate it